pues serían procesos diametralmente
Opuestos en muchos sentidos Este es un
proceso mucho más institucional diseñado
por el congreso que ya eligió un comité
de expertos en la mitad de 24 miembros
paritarios en la mitad el senado en la
mitad el congreso que ya está redactando
un anteproyecto que tiene 12 puntos que
tienen que seguirse y sobre el que se
elaborará un texto que será entregado a
este consejo constitucional formado por
50 personas frente a las 155 de la
convención de la convención
constitucional anterior en la que había
una gran representación dos tercios de
candidatos independientes Este es un
nuevo proceso mucho más
canalizado por las instituciones y los
partidos políticos en Chile López
explica también una parte de la
desafección de la ciudada